an eight-year-old little girl is getting
national attention for dressing up like
a young version of her hero for her
school's cultural heroes de ello
lorraine brown perfectly matched
Michelle Obama's outfit when she was a
college freshman at Princeton University
that's great inspiring young people is a
big big theme of the former First Lady's
memoir it's called becoming it is the
best-selling book of 2018 mrs. Obama has
just revealed her book tour will make 21
more stops in North America and Europe
in 2019 in our very popular series note
to self she advises her younger self as
she leaves for college
dear me SHhhh
there you are in your jean jacket and
braids a long way from that little
apartment on the south side of Chicago
you're at one of the finest universities
in the world you're smiling and you
should be you worked hard for this but
even now after you've reached your goal
you're still not quite sure if you
belong and can't get one question out of
your mind am I good enough
there aren't many kids here who look
like you some arrived on campus and
limousines one of your classmates as a
bonafide movie star
another is rumored to be a real-life
princess meanwhile you got dropped off
by your father in the family sedan years
from now you'll learn that your parents
had to take out new credit cards to pay
your tuition but Michelle what you'll
come to realize one day is that you're
only seeing what you lack and not
everything that your story has given you
you grew up surrounded by soul and jazz
and a deep anchoring love your parents
taught you to keep your word and treat
people with respect they encouraged you
to develop your own voice and use it
those lessons are more valuable than
anything material they'll come in handy
in the future in settings I won't spoil
for you right now
your father's final lesson will come far
too soon he'll teach you that life is
fleeting
so laugh with him until your side hurts
savor the grip of his hugs the softness
in his eyes a day will come when those
memories are all you'll have his absence
will hit you like a rock it'll cause you
to rethink everything about yourself and
your future but don't worry you won't
have to go through any of this alone
you'll open your heart to someone whose
upbringing was nothing and everything
like yours all at the same time he's
driven by a hopeful set of ideals he's
grounded and kind and absolutely
brilliant and he's pretty good-looking
too I thought you'd appreciate that
[Music]
his certainty about his path will feel
like a challenge to yours you'll learn
that even the best relationships take
work but that's okay that's normal and
it's what gives your partnership its
strength together you'll be blessed with
two perfect little girls who will fill
you with so much joy you can barely
process it yet
you'll still struggle to find a balance
between your family your husband's
rising career and your own sense of self
be patient you'll get there and just
when you think you've done it the four
of you will be shot out of a cannon into
the unknown thing you've fought for so
hard stability balance confidence will
feel like it's at risk you'll be
attacked by people who've never met you
and don't really care - they'll try to
harm you for their own gain don't stoop
to their level no matter how gratifying
it might feel in the moment hold tight
to those values your parents taught you
you treat people
with dignity and respect
even if you don't know them and even if
you don't agree with it your family will
make history breaking barriers and
filling out a more complete picture of
the American story at this defining
moment change has come to America
with a lot of hard work and a good
education anything is possible
you'll meet two popes and the Queen of
England you took on a role you didn't
ask for and you made it your own with
grace and with grit and the style people
will fill stadiums to hear you speak
she is your hometown girl from the south
side of Chicago welcome
it will be easy to think you're
something special just remember that
there are millions of people who grew up
like you did and don't get this kind of
spotlight reflect the light back on them
use your voice to speak out for what's
right to build a better future for the
next generation to encourage those who
are too often silenced or shoved aside
there are so many people out there like
you mesh black girls and minorities of
all kinds working-class kids from big
cities and small towns people who doubt
themselves who are uncertain about
whether they belong but have so much to
offer the world
[Music]
share your story with them the struggles
and the triumphs and everything else
show them that there's more beauty
inside and they can see right now that's
how you'll answer that question that's
following you around the one that
sometimes keeps you up at night you're
more than enough Miche you always have
been and you always will be and I can't
wait for you to see that gosh because we
sure see it mrs. Obama it's so
interesting and becoming just happened
to have a copy right here on the set
this book is sold already three million
copies and on page 66 she writes when
she was in high school her counselor
told her that you're not Princeton
material so for her to do a note to self
based on starting with going to
Princeton and how her life has evolved
there are so many notes out of that shot
out of a can and reflect the light back
on to them she really does live the life
of when they go low we go high it's
extraordinary well I think that message
too for many people there's more beauty
inside than they can see right now in
everybody that's the becoming really we
talk shows the total of that book and be
patient you'll get there it's a hopeful
message I'm gonna take that platform and
that line reflecting light back on them
that's the thing is with what to do with
Fame and that platform is to lift
everyone up to bring everyone else up
who had this we are now having the same
doubts you had it's the core of the
foundation was really her family right
in that image of her dad dropping her
off do you see the love right there it
all starts with that so we really do
have to thank Dana Brewington jenna
gibson who were involved in that piece
and certainly to you Angela Ross because
the Edit was perfection I want the
soundtrack to that very very very nicely
done we published a book based on our
note to self series note to self
inspiring words from inspiring people
it's on sale right now
thinking if there's a version to
Michelle Obama's is going to be in that
one is published by Simon & Schuster
which is it
CBS